well thank you hello everyone my name is
taylor rogers and welcome to the rn
manufacturing webinar on today's talk
i'm going to tell you about how we use
rstudio's shiny product to help a
manufacturing client save money and
improve quality
i'm going to share some of the project
requirements or at least the part that
i'm actually allowed to share with you
guys
i'll do a brief app walk through the key
functionality that was used in
facilitating the
app rollout to
the plant workers on the plant floor
i'm going to tell you a little bit why
we went with shiny as opposed to many
other data science application tools on
the market
and also do a brief code walkthrough at
the end now if you're wanting to know
the exact
step-by-step programming details of this
application we're going to be
demonstrating i'm not going to go into
too much detail about that today
but we are actually going to post a
how-to article after this talk that will
actually teach you how to replicate what
i show you today so if that's something
that's going to interest you i'll uh
encourage you to check that out
afterwards
and we'll also have some times for
questions at the end if you have any
um let me give a little bit more of an
introduction of myself though as you
already know i'm taylor rogers i'm a
senior data scientist and project lead
at pk global
in my role i primarily build data
science applications usually those that
incorporate machine learning my primary
tool for doing that is shiny
i have a master's in applied statistics
from the university of kansas medical
center
and as you can tell tell by the picture
of me holding a book i'm a writer as
well i write a lot about data science
topics uh the book i'm holding there is
called data work
this is a book i actually just released
a month ago if that's a subject that
interests you you can actually buy it on
my website or on amazon.com
um another project i'm working on uh
this one i think will probably be more
interesting to people on the call is our
programming in plain english uh this is
a book i'm writing i'm about
ninety percent of the way done i only
got one chapter left but it's actually
available for free online to those who
need it it explains our programming in a
as non-technical of a way possible to
people who don't have any programming
experience but find that they need to
use r for their academic research or
maybe they just started as a data
analyst and need to learn a good
statistical programming language so if
that's you that's the book for you and i
strongly encourage you to check it out
but that's enough about me let's talk
about why we're here today we're here to
talk about our manufacturing
uh what does that actually mean in this
context well we built shiny apps
basically um for our client uh for those
who don't know uh shiny app is an
interactive program
that runs on top of r
the one you see here in the screenshot
is the one i'm going to demonstrate for
you in a little bit but
you can use shiny to build data
visualizations dashboards
data entry input forms for uh databases
there's a lot of possibilities with this
tool
but there's actually only so much that
i'm allowed to share with you about this
project
the reason is is our client is a defense
contractor and for that reason they very
highly value secrecy and they gave us
their blessing to talk about this
project but we can only share with you
key information about it so for example
i'm not actually allowed to tell you
what our client's name is um i'm not
allowed to tell you the product that
they build
and i'm not even allowed to tell you the
inputs we use on the algorithms that we
included in this project
that might have some of you asking
what's the point of this webinar then
how do you present a case study on
manufacturing when you can't even
mention the product or the client and i
think that's a fair criticism if you're
thinking of it but ultimately what i'm
hoping to show you today is not
necessarily anything about our clients
product but how we use shiny to improve
their manufacturing process and why
shinee was the tool to do it
um
but the project requirements that i can
share with you though
um
they're kind of broad our client
approached us and they said they wanted
to build
predictive algorithms that could be used
to
predict the performance of a product
based on the chemical inputs
so in this process there's about a
the manufacturing process itself takes
about a day
but at the very beginning of that
there's a mixing process of of various
elements and chemicals
and that process takes about 60 to 60 to
120 seconds about two minutes
and it's not just about mixing element a
with element b at a ratio of 70 to 30
percent what actually impacts the
performance of their product
is the rate at which those chemicals are
injected so you might have element b
injected at a rate of 5 grams per second
at the beginning of that two-minute
process and then it increases to 15
grams per second as it proceeds
um that ultimately affects the quality
of the product that they're building
um
they were hoping that we would develop
machine learning algorithms that could
better predict the performance of those
products based on how long and how fast
those chemicals were injected during
that process
the other key detail that they wanted us
to deliver with this project the other
big requirement
is that they wanted to democratize the
machine learning models um
rather than have an office manager very
far away from the plant run these
calculations with the model and then
send it to the plant workers and say do
this
they actually wanted to build
they wanted to provide those machine
learning models in such a way that the
plant workers could actually make their
own predictions so the person doing the
mixing
could do the prediction and then make
their decisions on how to
mix those chemicals together and at what
speed
um this
is a very important feature because
even though the actual mixing process
takes maybe one to two minutes um
the process that follows that afterwards
with
continuing the production process can
take a whole day
and it's very energy intensive it takes
a lot of time and not only that if they
do it wrong they actually
lost most of the resources that they
spend on it
it's a lot harder to
recycle those resources to get it right
the next time so it's very important to
find a way to put this model
in front of the plant workers so they
can make the predictions in real time
and go about their jobs afterwards in
the best way possible
how exactly do you do that well you have
to build an interactive user interface
um that's what the client approaches and
say
they actually had a mock-up and said
we'd like you to build this application
for us
um as anyone knows who's worked in this
industry for a long time it's actually
very rare that a client will ever come
up to you and tell you the exact thing
that they want in the requirements but
we got very fortunate in this instance
that we were working with a client who
uh
could think out things like that ahead
of time and provide a plan for us to
follow
usually
if a client approaches you with an idea
like that you have to help them flesh it
out a little bit more concretely but we
got very fortunate in this case but let
me actually show you the
um part of the app that i am allowed to
share with you
um
this right here is the shiny app you
might remember from that screenshot i
showed earlier and this is not the
actual application we showed the client
or we deliver to the client this is the
application that you can build on that
how-to article we'll post later um these
three tables right here are not really
relevant to this demonstration but
whenever you follow that how-to article
you'll actually be able to see
how what you're building impacts things
on the back end with these three tables
that's meant to be a guide for that the
part that was on the application
that we deliver our client is what you
see on the left here
this may look like just a normal line
graph
that reports something like on any other
dashboard or application but what this
actually is it's actually the inputs
that feed into the predictive algorithms
that we built if you notice on the uh
x-axis we have time uh
this particular example it's actually
seconds 70 seconds worth of time
and you see speed on the y-axis
this represents the rate at which those
chemicals were injected that i talked
about earlier and each one of these
individual dots
actually represents model inputs
now what is how would the
plant workers on the plant floor
actually use something like this well
what the client said they wanted us to
do
was give the ability to the plant
workers to click a dot
and move it up here
and what they're doing is changing the
model inputs that feed
into the algorithm
and the reason why they were able to use
this so until intuitively is that it
actually mimics the process that they
would use for the chemical injections
themselves uh this is very similar to
what they're gonna see on their own
uh machinery interface uh when they
actually do the mixing
so
that was the big ass that they had they
also said they wanted the ability to
hand type the input so well you see here
you can get pretty close to 50 and let's
just say the
plant worker wanted to make it exactly
50. we wanted to give them the option to
do that as well to give very precise
numbers and also maybe change this to
something more precise as well
that was the other key requirement that
they had for this user interface
and even though you only see
a shiny matrix here that's what that's
called and you see a plotley graph here
there are actually uh
three of these there are three of these
plots that were used as model inputs for
the different chemicals that they
represented
and uh this was a
big feature that allowed them to
build the modeling so how that would
actually work on the client app is after
they selected all their model inputs and
uh dragged it and placed it where they
wanted it to go
they would hit a button that say
simulate
it would pass that to the model
parameters and then they would see the
predictive performance on the right hand
side it would give them an indication on
whether they were meeting the
requirements for that particular mixture
that they needed
that's what our client asked us to
deliver and not only that
they also had these certain rules that
we had to make sure the end user
followed
like for example you know you can't
really have a negative time
at least in this context i guess you
can't really have negative time in any
context but uh for example if they
wanted to try to change the zero value
to something further left it would have
to revert back to zero same with this
last value of 70 we had to make sure if
they try to change that to something
sooner it would kick it back to 70.
these rules were not only in place
because they reflected the reality of
the actual chemical mixing but because
we had to do that for the model inputs
we had to make sure the model inputs
followed those rules before they got
inserted into the algorithm otherwise we
would have gotten
uh incorrect conclusions
so that was the core functionality they
were needing they were wanting a user
interface that mimicked the actual
manufacturing process that those plant
workers would see
and allow them to make those predictions
uh in real time
now
um having said that why why was it that
we ultimately went with shining how did
shiny become the tool that we built for
this project
and um
you know our client actually came to us
directly and said that they wanted to
use a shiny app but
even if they had come to us and said uh
these are the requirements we have this
is the interface we want you to build
what tool would you
recommend we use to build that we
probably still would have said shiny
anyways
now why is that i actually want to
explore that question for a moment
because
uh this is something i've often asked in
my own career of myself
up until
maybe about a year ago i've pretty much
ignored shiny for doing this kind of
work i even though i loved our
programming
i preferred a different tool i preferred
to use tableau
now for those of you who don't know
tableau is another
uh
dataviz dashboard building tool that you
can use you can often build something
that looks a little bit like this
it's become very popular in the past few
years and something that's often asked
for whenever you pursue a career in data
and analytics
but it's not just tableau you also have
power bi you have domo
and um these are often what people think
about using for whenever they build some
kind of user interface that contains
data
i often see people kind of ignore shiny
and there's a lot of reasons for that
but i think it often comes back to this
question of why do i have to hand type a
data science application
and what i mean by that is if you look
at the user interface for tableau
um
it's much more visual like what you see
this bar graph here and i was able to
create it by just double-clicking a
dimension and double-clicking a measure
and then you get a data visualization
there's a little bit more nuance that
goes into tableau than that but um
you're building a visual medium and you
get to see it visually as you build it
that's kind of the big appeal of this
tool
shiny on the other hand oh where's my
mouse shiny on the other hand
you have to hand type everything it is a
tool that runs on top of our programming
so you have to know r
and you have to hand type everything
that you wanted to do
this script that you see on this
powerpoint slide is actually the script
that supports that app that i was just
demonstrating earlier and i can't even
fit it all on this powerpoint slide and
that app's not that complicated the
actual app we delivered to the client
had
well over a thousand lines of code
probably a couple thousand if i remember
correctly
and when you compare those other tools
and what you're trying to build and you
compare to a process like this where you
have to hand type everything it just
seems tedious
but it ultimately comes down to what
shiny strengths are what that big trade
off to hand typing everything brings
many other strains
that allow us to deliver this project
um
one of those strengths is you can tell
the app exactly what to do
you know it's often said with those
other tools uh
i've heard a few people say this now is
that they're really great at guessing
what you want them to do but with a tool
like shiny you actually get to
very clearly define the rules and
behavior you want to follow and it comes
back to the idea that you can hand type
them
it also allows complex interactions and
event tracking that was very important
to making sure that whenever the user
interacted with that plot and change the
model inputs it was actually the event
tracking that allowed that process to
occur
this one's a little bit more obvious it
allows easier ml model integration we
were building a machine learning model
for our manufacturing client and we
built it in r
and shiny runs on r so it's a lot easier
to have that model integrate much more
seamlessly in a shiny app than it is for
those other tools
this is a big one this one often gets
forgot when i think we talk about things
like this it's the ability to create
data within the act
those other tools are more reporting
they pull data from a database or a data
set and then they report on them it's a
lot harder to
manipulate and change data within the
app or write to a database from those
tools but shiny on the other hand it can
write data to a database but in this
particular instance the big appeal to
shiny for delivering this project was
we're basically creating data
whenever the end user moves those plot
points it's creating data that's going
to feed into an algorithm as model
inputs that's a very important
feature that's often missing in these
other tools
and when you compare all these strengths
and
weaknesses of these tools
what i realized especially while working
on this project with these manufacturing
is that it really changes
who this tool is meant to serve in an
organization
i think it's about serving the subject
matter experts or the uh
uh more highly skilled uh workers that's
to me what shiny app is about not the
business stakeholders
what do i mean by that
you know when you're a data scientist
this is a very broad generalization but
broadly speaking you have two
stakeholders you know you have a
business stakeholder and you have a
subject matter expert
a business stakeholder is often like
your vice presidents your directors
sometimes their clients
and what they're often needing when they
contact someone like you to build a data
science application is reporting
they want to
measure performance over the past few
months and make a decision to adjust
their business strategy based on that
they want to see how well they're doing
to know how they should proceed in the
future
they often don't need modeling some they
often need modeling but it's outside the
context of building an application for
them usually they want an application
it's for reporting
the subject matter expert on the other
hand
um they often don't need a data science
application to make it easier to present
data to people they're often needing to
solve a problem
and that problem very often incorporates
machine learning and i actually think
it's this kind of stakeholder that's
often under utilized and it's because we
don't learn enough about
tools like shiny to help them when you
build them an application you're needing
to build something very specific that's
governed by the rules of that person's
uh job
and it often needs to incorporate
modeling
and that's what those plant workers were
they were basically subject matter
experts who needed
an application that could perform this
and that that's the big role i hope you
take away from this is it's what i
learned while working with these
manufacturers is that shiny just simply
does what those other tools can't do
it's about building an application for
subject matter experts who need advanced
functionality especially with statistics
that's big caveat
so
what was it about shiny though that
allowed that you know i talked about the
broad strengths the uh
kind of broad strokes of what uh
shiny does and how it can help them but
what i mean here is what are the
technical features that allowed that
well obviously you can hand type the
rules i already said that before but i
want to show you
that on this little snippet of code you
see here um you know earlier i said the
first input and the last input in that
model needed to be 0 and 70 well there's
just two lines of code and it doesn't
matter what the end user does it will
revert it back to it now just because i
wrote it on that script
there's also the various r packages and
the cool thing about our packages it's
basically you're relying on an entire
community of people who love our
programming
the obvious package that we use for this
was shiny that one's obvious that was
developed by our studio but there's also
shiny matrix even though it has the word
shiny in it this package was not
developed by
the people that developed shiny it's
actually developed by a different group
and they're the ones that built the
functionality that allowed me to hand
type those inputs we discussed earlier
they just foresaw a need by someone like
myself in the future to have that
functionality on a shiny app and they
just developed it there was also plotly
plotly uh foresaw a need for someone
like myself to build interactive
visualizations within shiny so they
provided the
functions needed to do that that ability
to drag and drop those plot points
is because of the plotly function
within shinyo there's also this concept
of reactivity this is another key
feature that made this app work
um more specifically we use the
combination of something called reactive
list reactive functions and event
observations
these three taken together made it
possible for us to see that the end user
was moving those
individual model inputs and then
reacting and rewriting the new data to
serve as the model inputs later
and i can actually show you a little bit
more of what i mean by that
um so if you see here we have the
uh app that i showed you earlier
and um let me think of the best way to
do this
um all right so now we can go to the
actual app script
that's what this is it's app.r
what you see here was generated by the
code here
and for those who don't know there's a
few components to a shiny app you have
your ui object
this is like the skeleton of the
application this determines where
this table and this table go and also
determines why you can toggle back and
forth between these two
input methods
then there's the server object this is
where most of the actual coding and
logic goes to support the functionality
it's where we
actually generate the plot if you look
here we have a render plotly function
and within that we actually have the
actual plotly function itself which
produces this plot
now ui and server those are the two
common uh
i guess you would call them objects but
there's also global objects and what you
see up here is this
matrix
which are the default values used so
whenever we open this application we
actually see these original values here
and no matter what we do those original
values are going to stay the same
because it matches what is in this uh
default matrix identified in the global
settings
now
normally if we were making a shiny app
that didn't require this uh
interaction like we do
we could actually
call upon that static data set in the
global environment and pull it directly
into the plotly one
and we would see those plot points just
fine as it is
but because we want to give the ability
for the end user to move those plot
points and update a data set that feeds
into the algorithm we have to do a
little bit more
steps and that's where this reactive
values list comes in
now pay close attention to something
here if you look right here it says 39
and 0.67
and over here in the reactive values it
says 39 and 0.67
when i move this plot point i'm going to
move it to around 50 and 1.
it stays the same in the original values
but it changes and the reactive values
that's because if we're going to do
these kind of uh interactions we have to
both read reactive values and write to
reactive values to make it work
and let me give you a broad overview of
where that's at in the code
so right above our render plotly
function right here we have a reactive
values list
i just call it rv
and i pulled the values for time and
speed directly from that default matrix
up above
that's why when you first open this app
the original values and the reactive
values are the same
next we
within
let's see within the render plotly
function we map
those reactive values to the circles
and we also produce
lines between them
in addition we configure the plotly
function to say we want the ability to
do uh interactions with it we want to be
able to change the position of the
shapes there
are on there and that's what those
circles are they're technically shapes
we also label this plotly function with
the
id speed s this is very important in the
event tracking
so um all that data you see in here on
this plot is not actually these original
values they're the reactive values that
have been copied from the original
values
um further down below we have the
observe event function
what this does
is i very specifically told it to
listen and keep an eye out on the end
user on what they're doing and if they
happen to move
a plotly point like they do and that
plot graph has the source of speed s
it's going to proceed with the
script within that function
right here um i won't walk you through
these line by line but basically what
this does is it extracts the new
coordinates so if i move this to 60 and
0.8 the new coordinates are 50 or close
to 60 and 0.8
those are the new coordinates and it
extracts those from the event data
it enforces the rules on top of them
which you see here that 0 and 70.
and it just rewrites it back to the
reactive values list above
so it's basically becoming a circle
um if i move this
it took the reactive values gave it a
new coordinates and then it updated it
back to the reactive value list
same thing if i tried to move this it
takes the new values make sure it
follows the rules if it doesn't it moves
it back and then re updates the reactive
values list the shiny matrix that's what
allows this right here where we can hand
type the inputs
it normally would it need to be put
inside an observe event function the way
we do this
functionality actually works pretty good
on its own that you don't have to do
that but because we had to make sure it
follows the same rules as the plotly
graph and also because we had to make
sure that we're um
syncing up these two input methods or if
you change one on one it needs to
reflect on the other we also had to pull
it into an observant function and apply
those rules but it's ultimately the same
principles you're seeing there
but
that's uh
where did my powerpoint slide go ah it
took me all the way back to the
beginning
[Music]
bear with me a moment sorry about that
yeah let's start here again
but uh yep that's ultimately how the app
works it uses a combination of packages
that were developed by the community um
the ability of us to hand type the rules
and the
reactivity concept all combined to allow
us to deliver an application
to the manufacturing plant workers and
achieve the goal of democratizing those
machine learning algorithms and
those plant workers are still using it
to this day and they made immediate use
about it and from what i've been told by
our client they're very happy with it
but that's pretty much all i got for the
presentation today um
if we have any questions i'm happy to
take those now
awesome thank you so much taylor
i like the thing we miss with virtual is
the actual like clapping after
presentation
thank you so much i'm uh just a reminder
to everyone that you can use the slido
link in the zoom chat
to ask any questions you can ask
anonymously as well and then just a
reminder if you do want to ask a
question live we are recording this
session so we'll be shared up to youtube
so i just want to make sure to point
that out again
but i see a few questions that have come
through already
taylor anna
the first one is from
javier asked the
editable table on the shiny app
this was from the beginning
of the presentation was this developed
with a dt package or stock shiny
uh you're asking about this table right
here the edible one
this is actually from a package called
shiny matrix
the one that allows you to uh just type
in and edit things as you need them to
and uh
it actually works pretty good on its own
you can download the package and just
put it into
the
ui component and if you don't really
need to enforce rules on it actually you
can just input it like that and it seems
to work pretty well
awesome thank you and i i see you had a
he had added i think the code answered
my own question so sorry i didn't see
that before
um no worries
there's another question that came in
that is how long did this development
take prior to releasing it to the client
oh i love that question um
it
i actually don't quite remember so the
good news is we were able to divide up
the work a little bit so a colleague of
mine named pablo lopez did most of the
model building
and
you know usually i'm not like a big fan
of divvying up work within a project i
like to try to do most of it myself but
it was actually a very good thing that
we did that because uh the modeling
building aspect
required a lot more uh study of how the
manufacturing process worked and how to
transform
those time series like inputs into
something the model could read um the
part that i did probably took if we
added up all the hours maybe
160.
i don't think it would take that long if
i were doing it again today the reason
it did take that long was uh
i was having to read up on a lot of this
functionality as i did it um i didn't
know how to make a plot move like that
and the way it did i didn't even know if
that was actually possible within shiny
it was actually this project that
demonstrated that value to me um i had
to read a lot of stack overflow comments
and read up on other blog posts and
resources out on the internet and so
with all that research time and trying
to build many proof of concepts along
the way it took me about
maybe
140-160 hours i would estimate
thank you
and as i read the questions as well if
it's your question and you want to jump
in and add more context feel free to
unmute yourself and do so
christian i see you asked
a question around shiny matrix you said
does shiny matrix allow for copy and
pasting multiple cells at a time or is
it single cell input
well i think it is just single cell
input but they actually have a lot of
little uh
they have a lot of little settings that
can allow you to do more complicated
things so for example there's a setting
that allows you to uh as you fill out
the last row it'll actually add a new
row if you want to add a new one um as
far as copying it doesn't look like
that's on this version but
they may on their documentation have
information on how to do a
large copy and paste like that
thank you and if people have questions
you want to ask live too feel free to to
jump in as well
hi this is uh prabha
i asked how long it took question i have
a follow-up question to taylor
um
so you said it take you know 140 150
hours um but from a calendar time point
of view uh i'm assuming that that means
it took
maybe two three months to deliver
something to your client from the start
is that a fair assumption
yeah i would say so um
you know again
if i didn't have other projects yeah it
took about two to three months again if
i didn't have other projects going at
the same time and um i didn't have to
research most of these uh functionality
requests it probably would have been
faster but
um they they were pretty patient with
that they
actually had that extra expectation to
take about two to three months
well they have
actually the main part of my question is
were they happy with what they got for
waiting for two three months
yes very much so um
they the reason we were able to keep
them happy is we actually spoke with
them every week and we were able to show
them our progress so um
we didn't like go away and they didn't
hear from us for three months and then
we showed it we were on a weekly basis
we actually gave them updates of where
we were in the functionality and we
would explain the limitations we
currently faced with it and
that gave him a lot more confidence that
we would meet the deadline
um
and actually um also too we're actually
still working on this application we're
doing a version two now where we're
actually adding on top of the original
one with uh
additional models and um other types of
outputs
okay thank you for the answers no
problem
thank you
there's a an anonymous question that
came through
any recommendation on ci cd tools or
processes for a shiny project
uh not that i can think of at this time
if anyone else also we can open this up
we'll pretend we're like in a real
room together if anyone else has
feedback on that as well feel free to
jump in oh i actually just see another
question coming how do you deliver this
product to the client as an r package
website containing the shiny app or a
set code in a zip file
well there's a few layers to that
question so
the actual plant workers open it up on
rstudio connect that is a tool developed
by our studio that allows you to deploy
these applications and
the end user can log into that interface
and select whatever app that they want
to see delivering the app to them was
actually a little bit more complicated
because uh as i said they're a defense
contractor and they have a lot more
rules in place for uh
connecting systems together so
we had the data sets to build the models
on our side and
we were able to do that all on our own
computers but we actually had to send it
to them as a zip file for them to deploy
themselves so it was a little bit of a
tedious process because of those
uh secrecy restrictions but um
ultimately it wounds up in our studio
connect which is a great tool by the way
we actually
manage and administer that tool
ourselves
um
here at pk so it's pretty good for that
kind of purpose
thank you and um just a reminder if you
want to it might be helpful to use slido
as well just so i can see all the
questions in one but i'll answer the
questions from the zoom chat that are
there right now
i see jose just asked integration
between
shiny and using sorry using r and shiny
and python using reticulate package does
this give new possibilities to modeling
do you have any hints on this
um that's a good question and i'll be
honest i uh i've only done it from kind
of like an academic practice scenario
with using the reticulate package
and that was a few months ago and i
don't remember the exact steps that i
used to do it
so i'm probably not the best person to
ask about using incorporating python
models with our models
for this particular project we
ultimately went with the r models um
which are pretty easy to
uh reference within a shiny app
or though maybe you could describe that
um
that your partner pablo is more a python
guy how did he have to deal with it yeah
he uh
my uh colleague pablo he really wanted
to use python for this application and
um the challenge we ran into is there
was a subject matter expert who was also
a consultant
on the client side
and uh he was very much an r guy and he
uh
he asked us specifically to use r
whenever we were doing it and
giving uh updates on performance so
um we almost did actually use python for
the modeling building and or
incorporation just because that's what
the uh machine learning engineer on the
project knew but
um just for other
uh kind of more practical reasons we
switched it over to r before
delivering the project so
thank you
and then for a lot of the questions
around what packages
you've used
shawn just asked did you use tidy models
for the modeling
um
no is uh i
and truth be told i don't remember the
actual package that my colleague used um
but for the modeling that i did i've
used the carrot package
i do want to learn the tidy models
package though that one's very exciting
maybe it will be a
little bit more straightforward to use
if i
finally get the time to investigate it
and it may be helpful just because we
have so many people from the
manufacturing community here as well if
if anyone feels like sharing what
packages they find useful just for
general
work or it might be helpful to kind of
collect those
um or maybe there's already a crayon
task view
for some of that
but if you feel like just adding it to
the chat window please do so
one other question that i'm reading over
from the slido
um what is your thought process on
troubleshooting or building apps with
reactive values
and functions
i actually like this question uh if
anybody can think of an easier way to do
it i would love to hear it um but what i
do
it's very much the same process you see
on here so this um
this how-to article you know it's gonna
walk you through all the steps but i
often tell you to keep an eye on these
three tables you see here that i just
went ahead and provided so as i'm
troubleshooting it i actually have
raw data table outputs over here to make
sure that the data is doing what i
wanted to do that's what allows me to
know that the reactive values list is
updating in the way that i wanted to
um
i also built it's not on the demo app
that you're going to see on that how-to
article but i also had other tables like
this to
watch what was happening with the event
data the new coordinates that i was
extracting
that made it a lot easier for me to make
sure the right steps were being taken at
the right time as i was developing the
app and
as you write it i would just hit run app
or refresh app and then i could see what
it was doing after i changed the code
that's a great question though
if anyone has an an easier way of doing
that kind of work
i'd be happy to hear it because i
like to see what happens to the data as
i do it
mio i see you're unmuted
go ahead
um just to chime in at least on my end i
have kind of a standalone rmd or
you know dot r script that kind of
uh
pairs up against all my shiny apps so
that i can actually see what's happening
you know much easier like i think there
are some tools out there for kind of
live troubleshooting or being able to
see
you know your reactive
outputs um
but i've found that those have
limitations when you start using modules
um
or trying to communicate or pass data
between modules
um so yeah i just have like a standalone
r script where i try to run these things
on
that's interesting you say our script
connects directly to the shiny app or is
it just no no it doesn't it's just my
way of being able to prototype sort of a
engineering pipeline that then i'll
transfer over to
too shiny i mean i've that's one area
where i still struggle is just
troubleshooting
you know
anything that has to do with the
reactivity or like reactive values or
reactive polling like there are things
that are still sort of you know tricky
because you can't see and the the
the errors are often very limited
the error messages yeah
um i actually kind of like what you're
talking about and that was another thing
we did as we were building this um and
in hindsight if i were starting this
project again i would have made more uh
heavier use of modules to do this
because we were practically doing that
already and not with the actual modules
but following a similar process where
i'd often build smaller proof of concept
applications um
where i would just zero in on one unique
aspect of the functionality they were
wantings so
the uh actual drag and drop plots
when i was initially building that i had
only uh
i was just making an application just
with that on it and kept practicing with
it so that i could review my code and
make the right updates at the right time
and there's a lot of other
very specific functionality that they're
requesting that i can't share with you
but i had to follow a similar process
with that where i would uh
create just an app that focused on that
so i could get the steps down before
putting it together lately later and the
one thing that i learned from that
process that um
if i were doing that again i probably
would have made a heavier investment in
learning how to use modules to pull it
together in the end because i was
already building it one small piece at a
time it'd have been nice to just be able
to
import that as a module later on rather
than copying and paste it but
that's a lesson i learned kind of late
in the production process so couldn't
cleanly go back and fix it
what do you mean by modules that's a
great question um
this is something that i'm still
learning myself but modules allow you to
break a shiny app into smaller
components
and reuse those components across shiny
apps is that probably the
someone else may have more experience
with me but that's how i would think of
a module um it allows building it piece
by piece and then pulling it together at
the end i totally agree with that i mean
i you know modules to me are just kind
of like more robust functions
that
when used with shiny um
you know is is coined the term
chinese modules but you can use it for
individual plots you could use it for
entire uh tab items or menu items to
kind of iterate through different
subsets of your data i mean there's a
lot of different ways in which you could
utilize modules
um katie i said someone just asked is
there our studio blog or document on
this would you be able to share that in
the chat maybe
yeah actually um
or sorry i was just asking someone from
our studio to do it in the background if
that's helpful yeah so if you see this
blog post here this is actually the one
i wrote uh for those of you who want to
replicate the
uh the functionality you saw here today
this will take you step by step i'll put
it on the chat box now
this is the more in-depth technical
tutorial for what we have here today
awesome thank you
there's quite a few questions around
like how you deployed this and i know
you said that you've used rstudio
connect
but specifically like
for a client is it on their internet or
is it on cloud services like aws
um it is
wherever they just stalled i actually
don't know the answer to that for that
particular client i know for us as we
were building it internally we use the
rstudio connect server
and for us that's on our own uh linux
hosts that we manage ourselves and you
can this is what our studio connect
looks like for those who don't know you
can deploy
applications and our markdown files and
even schedule jobs in it
the way you would deploy it uh excluding
how we got that over to our client we
just sent them the script in an email
that's literally all we did was we saved
the scripts and sent an email and said
this is how you should structure your
file directory but hypothetically if we
had access to their r studio system
um we would have just published it by
clicking this button
and then it would go to the uh we can't
see your screen if you were shopping oh
i'm sorry you guys have no idea what i'm
talking about
let me start
so this is what our studio connect looks
like um it we this is our own version
that we use internally uh it's it exists
on a linux server
um
i think ours is ubuntu and right here
you know this is where we developed the
app
in our studio pro now you can the way we
transfer this to the client for them to
deploy we just sent them the
um
the r scripts that supported the app and
we just said make sure it follows this
file directory
we also had to provide some model
files which are called dot rds files and
just say make sure you place it in this
directory in relation to this directory
and you can deploy it and it should work
um now as far as like what technology
they use to deploy that and how they
deployed it i don't really know at the
top of my head but if i were if i had
direct access to their rstudio connect
server i would have just gone here
and said
uh i guess other destination and then i
would have just published and there's a
little bit more to it to connect uh our
studio to that but that's how you deploy
one of those
um
you know i i from what i gather i i know
you can deploy
these shiny apps
into a website environment i believe but
i don't know how to do that
myself at least
going back to
a few of the questions on
troubleshooting shiny i see people have
shared a few things in the chat as well
and jake said the browser function can
be extremely useful
and i see paul you just asked did you
use react log at all to troubleshoot
uh
now uh actually though i think the
person who is quality checking my app
for me use react log but i didn't use it
personally
uh i'll have to actually check that out
and see if it's uh useful for doing what
i wanted to do
going back over to the slido for a
second and um
i see persona asked if given a free hand
would you use
shiny and r or dash and python for such
applications
could you tell some of the reasons for
your preference oh i really like this
question so keep in mind um i've only
ever done anything with python more from
an administrator perspective so
as part of my team my responsibilities i
build shiny but also help administer
rstudio workbench
now within rstudio workbench you can
actually build dash apps
you can use python and you can use
reticulate to combine the two
but just from my experience i don't
actually know much about python
programming
i'm an r guy and so that's what my main
tool is but i've had a lot of trouble
from an administrator perspective in
managing python versions making sure
that they're using the right package
repo
and i'd like to think i'm a very
organized person that would be very good
at that but it always feels like there's
all these little
nuance rules to python management from
an administrator perspective at an
enterprise level
that
seemed to conspire to prevent it from
being a smooth process that may have to
do with my own limitations of
experience using python but
for that reason i like r better it just
seems easier to manage the package
easier to manage the python version
usually
even though there's lots of crayon
repos sources to download packages
across the internet they all basically
serve in the same way so you don't have
to worry about downloading a package
from anaconda or from uh pip or wherever
else it comes from you just download it
from crane and it seems to work so for
all those reasons i described my
background as an r from an administrator
perspective i have a lot of trouble
managing python
um
in an effective way at an enterprise
level for those two reasons i would
always probably go with r shiny um
one day i may change that tune uh our
clients often ask for both shiny and
dash app development and um i may have
to buckle down and learn how to use
python and dash so
maybe you can ask me that again in a
couple of years and i can give a real
answer to that but as of right now i
don't think i have enough experience to
say one's better than the other but i
would prefer shiny myself
dude tony says never
never with python or never with r
so if anybody um also wants to jump in
and and ask questions live too as we get
to the end of the time here i can take
you as unmuting as raising your hand as
well
um
and i say can you just unmuted
um i was wondering um like if somebody
just wants to test out an r studio
connection um or sorry rstudio connect
and
see if they can just share with like
just their friends and just test out um
just a production
if that is possible with like just a
free version of our studio connect or
like
if that's possible
that's a very good question i actually
don't know enough about the uh
how to trial our studio products to
answer that that might be something the
r studio team can answer
i could answer
that um
so anyone can feel free to reach out to
me directly and i could connect you with
the right person on our team
but yes you can definitely try it out
for free
you could email me at rachel
r-a-c-h-a-e-l-rstudio.com
or if you just want to go directly over
to sales it's just sales rstudio.com
and so they can actually set you up with
a hosted evaluation too so you can just
get in and start playing around with it
in like
10 minutes or so
thank you very much
definitely and paul i see your and tony
also advocating for shiny apps io is
great as well
so if you're just
starting to use shiny you can create a
free account on there as well
and publish your apps there and then
there's some basic tiers where you could
add additional functionality
um
as well
paula tony feel free to jump in as well
well i wanted to add that that's why i
wanted to ask taylor um that
you can probably use that if you're
delivering these tools to external
clients you could
create an account and deliver the tool
to them and then they would have their
own personal link to demo your tool
where you push it out there and they can
play with it that might facilitate a lot
you know quicker feedback right i didn't
know yeah you guys have considered that
right because it's external but you push
from the same button then you have for
your normal connect
yeah
so actually i have a few things to add
to that yeah like with our existing
rstudio connect server we probably could
have generated them a username and
password so that they could have logged
in and viewed it from their systems
there was a security component that
prevented us from connecting directly to
their version of it though they have a
lot of firewall restrictions and
um
yeah just for security reasons uh
like we didn't even actually get access
to a
virtual interface until this last week
with them to actually uh log in as a
user over there so that's something we
actually just got last week even though
we've been working with them since uh
march
so
which is good i guess if you're in a
secret uh security profession it's good
that they have that many restrictions
but it did uh pose some barriers to
deploying this in a way and actually
kind of like your idea of actually
giving them access to a rr studio
connect instance so they could they
could have tested it out there first but
i don't even think about that to be
honest
i didn't mean that actually i meant if
you go to shinyas.io you could make a
different account that's not your
internal one and it's not their internal
one it's a posted one and then you push
your app to that
public hosted
you know place and they go and look at
that so it's not
unless you have a special tier it's not
going to be private but
you know for testing out functionality
that's enough but i think you can make
it past or protect it if you pay for the
services so but it's a cloud-based
version it's not your internal
so it's pretty nice
and i think paul you said that's exactly
what your group does so they use shiny
apps io um with the basic google
authentication
for client applications but it does
depend on
that data that you're you're sharing of
course you don't
probably can't be putting sensitive data
over that but definitely for like proof
of concept as well
there's shiny apps io where you can
create that free account or basic
different levels with basic
authentication
and then katie just shared in the link
as well if you wanted to do a full
evaluation of our studio connect
you can just go on our website and
request that too
is it okay taylor if we there's quite a
few more questions is it okay if we go a
little bit over
uh yeah i could probably do uh maybe
five minutes over
okay thank you
um and i do just wanna say for anybody
that has to drop um i know taylor showed
it briefly but he has an awesome blog
post that we just published today which
actually goes through all the
code and example from today
that you can use
um and then one other the zoom
formatting was very bad in the chat so
i'm just going to point out the links i
just shared
also on the r for data science online
learning community slack we just made a
chat dash manufacturing channel so
if everybody wants to kind of stay
connected with one another or ask
questions there
you could join that group
by just going to r4ds.io
join
i'll put that in the chat again right
now
and then the channel that you'll search
for is just chat
dash manufacturing
and so we just created that today
um and then as you scroll up in the chat
on zoom i also did share a meetup
feedback form if there's suggestions
that you have or topics you'd like to
see your industries
anything good or bad you want to share
with me anonymously
feel free
and then also a speaker
suggestion form too so
even if you want to maybe speak eight
months down the road but i are
interested feel free to use that as well
and that's all i have for announcements
there before anybody has a job a few
other just
quick questions
um scrolling through real quick
hey rachel uh yeah
hi
i joined a little bit late so is the
link uh there for this uh meetup today
the
link to the meetup itself for the
recording
yeah
yes so i will i will share the recording
to the meetup discussion
uh section as well
um so that you can access that
and
miles if you don't mind could you just
copy over the meetup link itself and put
it into the chat
yep no problem
thank you
awesome
um
just scrolling through to see which
questions we haven't answered yet um
one
last question was have you had any
problems or pushback from clients with
regards to using shiny and r packages
due to any licensing concerns or could
you talk a bit more about that
um no i'm
not in my instance um
most of our clients uh
this client in particular requested that
we use shiny and they had their own r
studio connect instance but uh the other
clients i work on we actually um help
manage
their rstudio products
and so
the only real difference is when it
comes to the uh
any licensing or permissions to use it
is
not necessarily with shiny but it's more
based around a preference of the data
scientists who use those tools um some
want to use dash
and some want to use shiny
but from a perspective of the licensing
i think those discussions were already
made before i even came onto those teams
to help
so i don't really have much to answer on
that aspect i'm afraid
and then i see mahad you just asked a
question around can shiny be used to
make models
service industry
and i might need a little bit more
context if you don't mind
unless kayla and taylor unless you know
what that question is
i can kind of i think i
i'm gonna guess what i think i
understand what you mean is that
how easy is it but maybe models within
shiny i'm not quite sure about the
industry component but um
you know since shiny runs on r it's
statistical programming it's very easy
to build models in our and what you can
do is you save it as a like a dot rds
file
and then within the actual shiny act
yourself
you place that dot rds file that has the
saved model results
um within a particular directory that
you can reference
and
um
you can use the shiny app and then a
function called predict that actually
just calls that and then applies it to
the data sets that we generated so
the uh model inputs you saw in that drag
and drop plot they're actually fed into
a function that just let's just predict
that calls upon that saved model
parameters and runs it on top of those
model inputs
and these models that we trained it took
many hours to train i'm actually
training some new ones right now for the
next version of this product but once
you actually have those models trained
and you save them as a rds file the
function that calls them and then runs
it just goes like that within the app it
doesn't take that long at all at least
in my experience
um did i answer the question
pretty well
i believe so okay todd feels free to
jump in
awesome so i'd love to if there were any
unanswered questions too um we'd love to
share the answers to those when we um
share the recording as well
um
i'll just share my screen real quick to
show people where
that slack channel
is
can you see my screen right now
taylor can you see yes i can sorry okay
perfect um so if anybody wants to join
this cha slac community it's the r for
data science online learning community
um and so
it's just r for ds dot io slash join
and in the search bar you'll just search
for chat dash manufacturing here
if you want to join us i'll put all the
links here
with the recording as well
but also on the meetup page and i'll
share it from my own
linkedin
but if anybody has any other questions
or feedback please don't hesitate to
reach out to me directly as well
i just want to say thank you so much
taylor for an awesome presentation and
thank you very much both together as
well that's great
thank you all so much for joining and
have a great rest of the day
thanks everyone
bye
[Music]
you